America's Got Talent season 15 premieres
tonight two night Tuesday May 26th 8:00
Eastern Time and one of the judges of
this show back here on the Rich Eisen
show is Howie Mandel how are you sir
I seem to be okay I'm just waiting for
the applause to die down give me a
second no there's no audience here we
are audience free Howie but I would tell
you if we had one they'd be standing
can't we just pretend we can we can
really but I heard you talking about
Tyson yeah I was at the Hollyfield fight
the one where he didn't blows he bit him
what that's the one we invent Evander
right and what's your recollection
garius night in my sports activity ever
in my life I couldn't believe what I was
seeing you know they stopped that fight
a couple of times before cuz I think he
was biting before yes but when he spit
that out I was close enough to say what
is he eating that he just fell look you
spit out his gum wait that's not gum
that's low by the way Loeb doesn't stay
fresh after for like a minute apparently
it doesn't know that you know that I was
just trying to make a joke I'll be very
honest with you Howie I shouldn't do
that I shouldn't try to no you should
you should and I love that you cop to it
no fact when I get back to stand up I'm
gonna use that message because when
there is no there is there is a
sometimes in every comics world yes
there are crickets right not everything
works not everything's at Jem yes but I
love following up in that silence hey
people I was just trying to make a joke
just trying try but the whole thing is
trying does a lot of heavy lifting and
in that statement because you know what
I mean because if you somebody says why
would you say that or what do you mean
by that then clearly it doesn't work you
had Payton on earlier I did indeed yes
oh my god did you watch yesterday that
was a that was uh what you think it
exciting a boring at the same time with
a blend of exciting because you want to
see sports but it gave me new ideas you
know I also produce on the side I want
to call like look like LeBron want to
see LeBron lawn bowling huh okay not so
much and to make it different than what
we saw not rain but with just an
overcast day of LeBron lawn bowling why
overcast does that add a little bit of
trying to because it worked yesterday
you know the cable stations hit a record
numbers it did and it was it was rain
for guys golfing in the rain splitting
of pants you know I just want to do I
just want to like I don't want it here I
wanted here to the formula of success so
I don't want to say oh he's just copying
what they did so I just wanted to be
overcast no rain you know it's
interesting how he cuz I've been I'm
kind of ready to go full circle here on
this conversation because of what you
said that it was watching the Holyfield
Tyson fight in person was the scariest
moment of your sports viewing life what
did that what did that displace what is
the second scariest moment that you've
ever had well you have to know who
you're talking to here and this is
pre-pandemic I've always you know people
are calling this pandemic I'm calling it
told you you know I'm just biggest your
merfolk there ever was so the fear of
any sporting event to you know I like
sports yes but and I and I predominantly
watch sports on television or listen to
sports on the radio but I go to things
because that's what people do and just
being amongst the crowd just being
shoulder to shoulder with people is
horrifying it has always been horrifying
to me you know and so that's so anything
that anything fine go ahead anything so
anything you're saying any any sporting
event you ever went to is what was the
scariest that you've ever been to is
what you're saying yeah yeah and and
every just being amongst people so where
else are you amongst that kind of crowd
of strangers and being touched by going
through a turnstile and that it's any
arena any Coliseum any place that I've
ever gone to see a sporting event is
terrible I go in terrified and I hope
that the game will kind of alleviate or
take my mind off of a pervasive darkness
that is going on in my head and it
usually does I can get into the game and
be distracted so now when I'm really
scared of the crowd and I have a really
good seat at a fighting match and I'm
just starting to ease up with the pains
of
man in the ring is eating the other man
and thus the scariest of all time Howie
Mandel here on the Rich Eisen show so
you I was gonna ask you that cuz so how
are you handling quarantine it's just uh
know that I've been in quarantine you
know I've been I have moments that
people see me on television where I'm
out of quarantine I live corn I live in
you know the the I felt responsible at
the beginning of this with the shortage
of PPE
I thought have I been hoarding have I
been hoarding it all from day one of my
career in 1977 I got known for putting a
rubber glove a latex a surgical glove
over my head where did I have that I've
been carrying them from the time that
they were available to the general
public because I didn't want to touch
things so I've actually given away all
my PPE and now that the world is living
clean I'm actually you know I don't know
that misery enjoys company but I'm
everybody's in my nightmare with me this
is horrible I I do remember that part of
your stand-up act I do remember that
where you would put the rubber gloves
yeah the rubber glove all over your head
and right way before and I had surgical
masks and I built another little guest
room off of my main house for when I had
kids and they got sick I would go into
the other room I was it was like a
rehearsal for this I have been
rehearsing all my life and now I'm an
expert at this that's why you call it
told you that's why it's what you and
hey your your memoir is called here's
the deal don't touch me see that and
that's that was a New York Times
bestseller five years ago you know free
I'm like the the Jewish Nostradamus oh
my gosh Howie Mandel here on the Rich
Eisen show and this is all that was all
purest and it was that that was pre
saying elsewhere I mean you're yeah that
was 1977 who would you do stand-up with
in 77 walk me through a night well in 77
you wouldn't have known but I get a
young comedian special I think at 80 or
81 okay on my young comedian special
which was way they used to do that
annually you know to kind of give a
showcase to the young kids sir who were
coming up so on my special it was me
Jerry Seinfeld come on I know what he
ended up doing Richard
Lewis Harry Anderson and me and it was
hosted by The Smothers Brothers at the
Roxy in LA on Sunset so who was the most
neurotic one on stage that behalf it was
just a short bus of neuroses like I
don't know who was more but we were all
pretty neurotic no the lease was
probably Harry Anderson you know sure
may he rest in peace right so but why
should we had Richard Lewis here on the
show once and I I think I asked one
question at the start and then he talked
and then that was the end of it it was
just it was a Mormon
that's why is the most neurotic because
it would happen I would have take him I
would have taken him Howie you know I
you know I've come you know at this age
and I'm an old guy now you know I've
become very comfortable with my
discomfort I'm uncomfortable hmm but I'm
very comfortable with it I'm also very
medicated I am you know I go and my
therapist through this pandemic it's
moved into a Justin for me he's a he's a
little upset but he's happy I've moved
him into a whole new tax bracket you oh
my god I don't know if whether you're
being serious or not that much I am
being I'm always serious but laughter is
the best medicine you know you are
unless you have diarrhea laughter is
that the best oh my god I tried stand-up
in college it was the toughest thing
I've ever done but it was the most
exhilarating getting people to laugh I
feel you know my analogy I love thrill
rides you know and I love like being
scared because maybe it's because I
medicated so I'm kind of flatlined most
of the time so I love excitement right
and the higher I'm being tossed and the
scarier it is and the bigger that drop
and the closer to death I think that's
comes the more I enjoy it's more my
adrenaline and that's what stand-up is
to me that's what getting up on stage
and going ladies and gentlemen Howie
Mandel and then I love like now after 40
years I got a safety net of a ton of
material but I love to not have material
I love when something technical there's
a glitch something happens not so much a
pandemic but short of this
demmick I enjoy trouble and I enjoy
getting in trouble and I enjoy and
that's the electricity on a GT which
premieres just 9 to NBC at 8 o'clock I
was literally about to make that u-turn
for you Howie and look at you're making
that u-turn I was about to do that
I was really about driving apparently
I'm driving your show it's great take
over now no it's great it's no it's
great I was literally about to say it
sounds like you were describing an act
on America's Got Talent
well yes you know these people show up
with their hopes and their dreams and
they're not for the most part incredibly
trained or haven't put a lot unlike
sports they you know when you show up on
the field or on the court just you know
you put in tons and tons and tons of a
lot of these people have but then they
don't have the experience of playing in
the real game and this is the real game
and to see that ah and that joy and that
fear in these people's eyes and then
within two minutes hopefully their life
has changed forever and their hopes and
dreams have come true and it's so
exciting you know there's one I'm not
giving away anything but tonight there's
a there's a viral video already on
YouTube they released last week from our
show there was a man who who was wrongly
incarcerated DNA freed him after 36
years in prison he was a kid and now
he's out in his 60s 36 years
he just got freed in March and all he
wanted to do he used to watch a GT on TV
he just wanted to sing and he comes out
he's it doesn't even you know he's never
even used a cell phone he's never 36
years is an eternity and he comes on our
show and sings the most heartwarming
tear-jerking rendition of don't let the
Sun go down on me by Elton John you know
if you haven't seen it go click on
youtube and watch Archie
well you were targeted it's incredible I
watch this over the weekend Howie off of
your Twitter feed just remarkable this
guy's story yeah and there's there's a
ton of those and and the beauty of AGT
is this is a platform beast and you're
going to take that ride with us the
beauty of tonight is we started taping
you know 17 days before the shutdown of
the pandemic so you're going to see the
crowd of 4,000
you're gonna see it won't be like the
it'll be a lot louder and more exciting
than the McCall's matchup yesterday this
is exciting for me because that's the
only sports that exist but the truth is
it's like it's like an old friend and
you'll be cloaked and cheering audiences
and tears and laughter and everything
and then the pandemic happened and we
got we didn't get shut down right away
they've removed our audience you'll see
that in a few weeks right so we have
these people performing like yesterday
you know but did they go tada and then
there's it's like crickets there's
nobody there except us for you know and
I'm sure Terry mentioned that we have
Heidi Klum back yes Sofia vegara
yeah it's just so beautiful and witty
and smart and funny and Simon and Terry
were all there but that's all that's in
the room when they go tada and then
Heidi got sick and luckily it turned out
it wasn't cope at 19 and but she was
sick and she was and was three of us and
then they shut us down and we started
looming and I'm just gonna watch it all
develop and we're unfold right and we
were just your eyes we were just you
know and we were just looking at the the
I guess promotional not the photograph
but they it's sort of a graphic where
you're all photoshopped clearly but you
do look the most socially distant I'll
be honest with you I am you look like
you're standing together you're talking
about yes the father yeah yeah yeah it
looks like they even photoshopped you
socially distant Howie I'll be very
honest with you so it looks like I am
socially distant I was born socially did
well also I've been you know I've been
married for 40 years yes and anybody we
had Mar 40th anniversary in lockdown and
my parents were me there probably will
not be a 41 we're in lockdown she's
really learned Who I am and what makes
me tick and she's really not happy after
four dates been married for more than a
decade yes knows what social distancing
is
don't touch me get away from me I feel
you breathing on me and now you can you
know you've got the best of marriage
exactly and now you've got the backs up
of honey I was just trying to make a
joke now you've got that back stop Howie
yes because it's no joke now people have
always said like I'm in Hollywood and
I've been married all this time pickle
how do you make it work well I was doing
you know 100 and 200 live dates a year I
was doing a GT I was busy I was not at
home and my wife was thrilled she said
distance makes the heart grow fonder a
pandemic in lockdown kind of just EPS
that all up and by the way you forgot
about turning uh people who open cases
into princesses Howie you did that
gotcha that's it don't pardon me my bad
I just screwed that one up I was in you
know you didn't she's always been a
princess in your eyes but she's a
duchess and Meghan Markell that's right
I don't know whether I was a prior to
that Chrissy Teigen as well she was also
there and then you're forgetting number
eight come on number eight being
pilloried Clinton my DVR tonight 8
o'clock NBC do not miss do not miss it
season 15 premieres tonight Howie this
has been awesome catching up with you
thanks for doing this thank you buddy
you be well right back at you you guys
see me that's how a man go there we go
well done
get a nice round of applause there you
go hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here